comme tous les matins l'équipe du cirque
Zavata vient nourrir ses animaux parqués
près du chapitau mais ce dimanche matin
un chameau et deux anânes manque à
l'appel si le chameau est récupéré 800 m
plus loin saint et sauf un peu plus tard
c'est la macabre découverte l'un des âes
est retrouvé près du campement la bête
est morte l'équipe du cirque retrouvera
ensuite l'autre âne dans l'eau des
douffes de la ville il a fait une chute
de 4 m celui-ci on a eu la chance de le
retrouver il était recouvert d'eau donc
jusqu'à ce niveau-là il s il a réussi à
se maintenir la tête à l'extérieur de
l'eau il a pris appui sur comme il y
avait des petites estrades de bois il a
pris appuis avec sa tête sur ses
estrades de bois d'après les premières
constatations les malfaiteurs aurent
fracasser le crâne de l'animal à coup de
barre de fer difficile de boucler
l'enquête dirigée par les gendarmes de
sainte mort de Touren puisquaucun bruit
n'a alerté l'équipe du cirque ce weekend
chez Zavata c'est la stupeur de les
perdre d'une façon si violemment de se
les faire tuer par des jeunes qui font
ça juste pour s'amuser pour nous ça nous
choque vraiment et puis c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment dégoûtant c'est écurant
seul quelques bouteilles vides ont été
retrouvé sur place on pense
manifestement à une soirée trop
alcoolisée qui aurait mal
tourné